current events are big business
human beings take pleasure in listening
to other human beings discuss recent
topics in popular culture even if they
have no expertise on a specific topic
will and chad you must now enter your
astonishing opinions on the alex jones
defamation trial this is talk and topic
time begin uh well doozy is correct in
that i am no expert in this subject i've
been watching it
you know i'm sure as we all have with
kind of just like a
pop culture entertainment value some
crazy [ __ ] has been going down on this
but correct me if i'm wrong this is what
has happened
alex jones for roughly the better part
of a decade has been going on his show
infowars saying that the sandy hook
massacre did not take place and that all
the parents are actors etc etc and now
some of those parents have sued him for
defamation yes that's exactly what
what's going on okay and he's finding
himself and who knows how much money
this dude has because he sells those uh
a bunch of supplements and [ __ ] and he's
just nutraceuticals and all that yeah
he's grifting on all that [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] and basically making a business uh
he's he is a conspiracy entrepreneur
right let's say but these parents have
sued him specifically for defamation and
as i understand it
sorry about that
the trial has not concluded and he is
ordered the first roughly 50 yeah the
first of a couple there's a couple other
people from different states doing him
as well but uh he has been ordered to
pay roughly 50 million dollars to the
the parents in this one trial after a
whole series of like i watched a bunch
of clips from this [ __ ] trial he's
crazy off the [ __ ] rails 100 of the
time in it
uh the that thing there was one clip
of him with the [ __ ] hole in his
mouth and the judge was like are you
chewing gum in here and he's like no i'm
massaging a hole in my mouth i got a i
got a hole in my mouth you know you can
have a look if you like there's there's
a hole and i was pushing my thumb into
it see no gum
please close your mouth i don't want to
see the inside look see that
yeah close your mouth i don't want to
see the inside that shit's all going
down but the bigger issue of i have a
big red heart
with blood
coursing through it hot blood
i'm a monster
i have no problem
skinning my neighbor if i have to kill
my neighbor and string him up
and
dry his meat to feed my daughters i will
do yeah i remember that i will eat you
um
yeah he's he's got some greatest hits
but you know what's weird about people
he does sometimes i have dreams where i
fly out
into the
into space
and i
i there's a black hole and i and it's
just pushing me forward and it's saying
go go in there figure out what it is why
figure out the answers and i go into the
black hole and then i wake up did he
really say that every morning
i don't know
okay so the bigger thing about this
trial at least as i'm to understand it
is
really it's an argument about free
speech he's arguing he should be able to
say whatever the [ __ ] he wants yeah
about anything whether it's live when
you fight the system that's when the cia
starts to pay attention to you
and they go
how come jones knows what
what's going to happen before it happens
and i've and i know people who have
smelled hillary clinton and barack obama
these people smell like sulfur
say that for real they're demons
they're demons
and if they bathe by the lake the water
that seeps off their sulfur
reptilian bodies is making the frogs gay
i remember that one
game wrong okay so yeah
okay so
he has gone to this trial god knows
everything except where god came from
he's been ordered god is the greatest ai
that god has ever created he's been
ordered to pay these families 50 million
dollars this is to some degree an
argument about free speech where is the
line when does it become uh actionable
if you're saying things that are not
true and it can potentially destroy
people's lives or hurt them in some kind
of way well that's bad chad you
shouldn't do that
swim towards light that's what we're
that's what we're learning here i'm a
humanist i i'm pro-human future
that's what i want so he's gone beyond
in his pro-human future he's gone beyond
the legal limit of what you can say now
he's been ordered to pay 50 million
dollars but one real interesting thing
that happened in this trial at least
from my perspective is that his lawyers
supposedly inadvertently sent
two years worth of [ __ ] text messages
on his phone to the prosecutors yeah
yeah yeah accidentally like are they
trying for a mistrial i'm not sure but
now all of those messages were not only
used against him in this trial to prove
that he was lying about uh what he
thought about the the sandy hook
scenario
but now that january 6th committee
i'm really having a problem this this
week i guess so
the january 6th committee
is now subpoenaing all of these text
messages that got sent so they're going
to take a look at that i think the word
is supining when you subpoenaing oh is
it no it's not oh i don't know man i'm
sorry i'm going to let you talk about
this but he i'm interested too okay alex
jones did go before the january 6
committee already and supposedly he pled
the fifth like a hundred plus times in
his uh
questioning with them and they haven't
shown any of that in the uh in the
committee hearings
not that i've seen i was just reading
some article about it the other day but
i think now these text messages and
emails that uh they're gonna get
are gonna essentially prove some of the
[ __ ] he was saying or pleading the fifth
about it's gonna give them the real
behind the scenes which the assumption
is at least as far as i'm reading it is
that
him roger stone the trump white house
were all kind of coordinating uh the
marches toward the capitol on january 6.
peaceful protests exactly so i think
these are peaceful protests for people
who are all
human futurists people that are they're
not in the cities
they're out in the countries
that are that make up the cities these
are people who who work the jobs in the
cities
that that people that people that people
work what
dude you know here's the thing about
this whole segment please this podcast
is like we don't we don't talk about a
bunch of [ __ ] we don't know what we're
talking about right we kind of know
about this though no we don't i have a
layman's understanding of it you know
that's what actually that's all podcasts
i'm gonna i'm shaking doozy's hand on
this because it's like why don't we [ __ ]
why the [ __ ] are we talking about this
stuff we don't need to talk about
everybody's talking about this stuff
yeah but that's what podcasts do wrong
it's like hey how about this alex jones
[ __ ] you're reading articles you're just
farting that out for everybody go read
the [ __ ] article why don't we just
have a doozy reading list you know what
i'm saying what i'm saying is this
doodzy wants us to talk about things
that we don't [ __ ] know about but
chad we kind of do though though that's
what i'm saying is you kind of know what
you're talking about here you and me
if if we weren't sitting here right now
recording an episode of dudesy you and
me might be talking about this alex
jones trial being like did you hear
about this you hear about this and we
throw out whatever details we know try
to come to a greater understanding you
do 10 minutes of your alex jones
impersonation like right
chad just doing it the ancient
egyptians these are people that how did
you make a pyramid 600 feet high in the
air with beams
thousands of tons look of of rock alex
as crazy as you are uh you do say some
things that are kind of interesting in
the realm of ufos and aliens
these are people these are these are
beings that have that have constructed
uh
cities like atlantis which i've been to
they got a great lobster roll place in
atlantis that i've been to
and the way that they do the hollandaise
sauce underwater is very different
because you can't yeah the custard you
know
it's impossible to warm it up at depths
of 5000 feet in the marianas trench you
can't warm up hollandaise atlantis is
fully underwater i thought maybe it had
like an air pocket or something
like a like an air bubble like it's in a
cave or something
yep and it's uh it's in a cave we call
that a cenote a grotto
a cenote in spanish
thank you moving on yeah we had a
conversation about the alex jones they
make the frogs gay
they make frogs they make the frogs gay
they smell like sulfur
people this is a war
this is a human war and i'm for a human
future and if you look see you see that
i got a hole in my tooth you see
i'm just shoving my
my tooth sit down mr jones i'm just
massaging the hole massaging the hole in
my tooth this is your perry mason moment
that [ __ ] judge i don't want to see
inside your mouth close your mouth i
don't want to see the inside of your
mouth sit down
it's like what the [ __ ] is our country
dude when like back to back we have this
johnny depp amber heard [ __ ] thing
and now it's this alex jones thing it's
just one after another like circus
performances with these defense
attorneys making massive errors like
where are they finding these [ __ ]
people you know for these high profile
trials they just like get somebody who
accidentally sends two years of your
[ __ ] text messages to the prosecutor
after you've basically perjured yourself
yeah saying no i don't those text
messages don't exist it's like okay but
we're gonna send two years worth of it's
absolutely insane to me here's something
that i would say that i don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm talking about which is what
doozy wants us to do because this is a
podcast after all
is this something that anybody people
already say this all the time ever you
hear it three times a day everything's
getting dumber everything's stupid and i
think that attorneys and [ __ ] like that
when they're in these high profile cases
they're not dot in the eyes and crossing
the t's anymore i know it's hard to get
uh i i don't know it's it's hard to get
a killer attorney it's hard uh it's just
money though the justice you have enough
money
well he has a [ __ ] ton of money so
what's his [ __ ] excuse i don't know
these people are real morons yeah i
think they might have done it on purpose
i would like to i'll try
for some mistrial here's what we got to
do here's our call to arms this is if
doodsy can do anything
it's to do this somehow implant us
as the attorney
at you as the attorney for alex jones
and i sit in as alex jones and we just
see and i'll get all geeked up and i'll
have my he has that weird [ __ ] beard
and his mustache is always a little
short and i'll get the wig and stuff and
we'll see if anyone can make a
difference and i will have
my
wisdom teeth pulled uh even though
they're still in there just so that i
can go yeah you see that look in there
you see that
that's sorry
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break it right
if you like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend and break a review
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then